you never get more in life by saying no
you can only get more in life by saying
yes the more I try to chase them and I
want to make the money I want to make
the money then you can see these people
they're so desperate they don't make
money you don't make money when your
wife needs money your family needs money
who the best going to help them if it's
not you need motivation watch a top 10
with belief nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from immigrating to Canada at age 14
knowing zero English and then failing at
13 separate businesses to becoming the
king of high ticket sales
he's Dan Locke and here's my take on his
top ten roses success vol 2
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one say a lot of yes you need to say a
lot of yes because you never get more in
life by saying no you can only get more
in life by saying yes say yes to the
opportunity say yes mediated a new
person say yes going to that new city
you want to try a lot of different
things sometimes a lot young people they
ask me well then what should I focus on
what what should I do what career should
I pursue or what's my passion I say how
the do I know you haven't tried enough
things you haven't fail enough it's like
if you only have tasted certain types of
food if you only taste a hamburger let's
say for example you haven't tried
Japanese food Malaysian food right
Indian food Chinese food how do you know
what's out there how do you know what is
possible how do you know what you like
you only try one thing you only stay in
one city
you've only hung out with a few people
in your whole life so you want to try
more things it's okay maybe it's that
online business venture that you want
you try ecommerce and it doesn't work
and you try Amazon it doesn't work and
you try to feel the marketing doesn't
work it doesn't matter what it is but
you need to try enough stuff I started
and fail at 13 businesses 13 businesses
before having my first success because I
was saying guest a lot of things most of
them didn't work out and that's okay but
I knew I found out what I don't want to
do if you don't know what you want to do
it's a great place to start
find out what you don't want find out
absolutely what you don't want and what
you don't want to tolerate so first
stage you need to say yes to say yes to
all kinds of opportunities knowing most
of them will fail most of them would be
a waste of time but you'll learn
something from that and that's okay rule
number two stand out people don't buy
products and services they buy stories
because when there are so many choices
out in the marketplace on the internet
any any any product that you want
there are hundreds and hundreds of
choices how do you stand out how do you
add emotions to a commodity a pen what's
the difference between a $2.00 pen like
this or a an $800 Montblanc John F
Kennedy limited edition exclusive pen
$800 pen it's the same pen it's the same
functions story when he asks story to it
to an item suddenly when you add the the
the John F Kennedy the president story
attached to a brand or logo it is ten
times more valuable it is a hundred
times more valuable it is 300 times more
valuable that particular pen all because
a story you're writes the same a $2.00
pen you can write to that's the
difference so think about what what's
the story
how can you inject stories into
everything that you do rule number three
show up you asked me all the time where
am i flying to your city where am i
going to fly to you dad loved to attend
one of your seminars when you come to my
city the answer is never what if I never
come to your city whatever never fly to
your town then what are you gonna do
what if I don't come three years five
years ten years you're gonna wait 10
years it makes no sense
don't wait nobody's gonna come rescue
you know what it's gonna save you you've
got to show up and you got to go to what
ever wherever it takes and remember
years ago when my mentor asked me and
say hey I won't have breakfast I flew to
LA just to have a single breakfast with
my mentor and you're waiting and you
waiting and what I what are you waiting
for waiting for me to come to the city
you're waiting for the perfect timing
you're waiting for everything is
perfectly lined up you're waiting for
what's convenient the problem is you put
your convenience ahead of your
conviction
convenience in conviction don't live on
the same block rule number four
don't quit I fail at so many pieces I
feel at 13 businesses 1313 Wow before
having what a white white court call
success right so from 17 to what age did
the homicides within three years so
three years thirteen businesses in and
about losses all losses or lessons yeah
no all losses no it's not as yeah yeah
it was in a max on my credit card and
lost on my mom's face savings yeah I
heard that at one point to your almost
over $100,000 in debt $150,000 $50,000
and how old were you at that time 20 20
years old 20 years old and that was just
different loans from your mom our
relatives relatives and my brown test
they wouldn't think might call anymore
cuz yeah yeah it's just I just borrow
from everybody that I could did you burn
a lot of bridges at that time to get I
did I did but I always promised them
that just let me like give me one more
chance right let me try harder and they
believed in me but they just thought
they always thought I was kinda odd when
the family it's like why don't you just
there and just go get a job but do
something like what normal people yes
safe they're safe and do something like
why do you have to have these crazy
ideas he's another idea of them yeah and
I just told them hey listen if I were
just to go get a job with my I don't
even have a college degree anything like
that I would be making me a man with
minimum wage listen I'm not $150,000
yeah if I was making minimum wage it
would take me forever right to pay you
off to pay you back and pay off all this
debt and to provide for my mom so like
people always look at what I did
oh you must be so motivated there it's
not motivation it was desperation right
it was I had no choice
rule number five don't chase money money
is a byproduct value creation of money
is not something when you try to chase
money it doesn't come to you the more
you try to chase them money I want to
make the money I want to make the money
you can see these people they're so
desperate they don't make money you
don't make money but if you are more at
ease
and you focus on delivering value yeah
money comes yeah let me think about
today how much you make the effort that
you put in versus they say for many
years ago where you put in a lot of like
hard work and you and I got make money
trying to make that $1,000 how difficult
that was for us now
1,000 bucks is like yeah it's so easy
what changed
yeah right yeah what changed it's a very
different mindset rule number six find
your why I think most people they don't
get what they want in life because they
don't know what they want so they lack
clarity and why do you lack motivation
chances are they haven't suffered a lot
of pain
you can see now we on a private jet
I remember
many years ago when I was struggling in
business couldn't pay the bills my
father had his first stroke and I was so
much in debt and I couldn't even afford
the plane ticket he was in the hospital
he was an emergency and I couldn't
afford even to buy an economy ticket
because I was in Canada and he wasn't
Hong Kong that incident that experience
just gave me so much pain when you have
enough pain
your motivation I said to myself I never
ever ever want to live there like that
again
whatever it takes I don't want to
experience so helpless that I couldn't
do anything in order to protect my
family in order to just have the freedom
the ability to to buy the plane ticket
I need money I need money when if you
want your kids suffer when your wife
needs money when your family needs money
Huda is going to help them if it's not
you and you don't get at that point
then what kind of man are we rule number
seven find the right mentors I saw this
book one day on eBay
I was just browsing around to look at
some stuff and I saw the title
captivated me it's called your first
hundred million mmm fun what kind of
book is this like that's a pretty bossy
title as a copywriter right that's a
good title right I click on it and I saw
that the price was $400 us for a book I
thought to myself who in the right mind
would spend for honey bug huh wait I
click on a link and he has the first
chapter in the listing I read I read
through the first chapter before you
know it I was the idiot that bought the
book I spent 400 bucks I bought the book
yeah I read through the whole book they
had such a big impact on me mm-hmm I
guess at the time I was already looking
for the second mentor because I was
already experienced success and Alan
wasn't well and I was looking for
something more and when I saw Dan penny
I can't pick damn right I saw big Dan
it's like this is the guy I wanna learn
from mm-hmm I caught the castle just
straight up I just called a castle how
did you get the number it's all in the
book yeah right now of course when I
first called called castle you got the
gatekeeper but I went through a lot of
like different things and I went to the
castle seminar and that's how and of
time big Dan wasn't as popular as today
it was I remember when I went to the
castle is like four or five guys I was
one of them he did it once a year I
think in the time he was maybe in
semi-retirement with Jaime and that's
again he's been my mentor now for more
than 10 years q in mine I was at a time
before the 25b 25-ish 26 something like
that then was making good money wasn't
giving me a half a million whatever a
year half nine a year how a million
years something like that and I would
call Victor and said tell me you know
hey man you know I'm pretty good point
someone years old making half a million
but I was me I put any guys right right
you feel pretty good about yourself
right point someone years I'm pretty
smart right
and especially after listening to advice
and make some changes so I call him a
talk so hey you know so
so he asked me how are you doing oh man
you know this time I'm not doing all
this stuff right so how much money
you're making now you know half half a
million bucks
very good silence so he said so what are
you half a millionaire yeah yeah yeah
that's him
that's it always doesn't matter what I
do every time I talk to him there's
nothing yeah
whatever you I I'm doing whatever
compare what he's done is nothing he
always gives you context to the bigger
game they go again
rule number eight learned from martial
arts and but I find that the martial art
philosophies have helped me a lot in
business I integrate them I do buy blue
belief is transferable for sure so like
in martial art I'd why why gravity two
words Bruce Lee's martial art because
it's about simplicity is about
directness mm-hmm
same thing in business I like to be
direct I like to go off using a similar
simple model yeah so it's the same idea
that's it so I think that affected me a
lot is the way I think rule number nine
get used to being uncomfortable you need
to be comfortable being uncomfortable
you need to get used to being
uncomfortable human being we don't like
discomfort you know how sometimes you
sit for too long and then you're like
all right I gotta I gotta change I gotta
change other you are very very
comfortable until you get uncomfortable
sitting for a long time then you want to
adjust right you want to you want to
move around that's exactly it you have
to make yourself uncomfortable on a
consistent basis the things that you're
afraid of to do the action you're afraid
to take the risk you are afraid to take
you guys take it when you feel
uncomfortable you know what I'm
conditioning myself a success and rule
number ten the last time we for a very
special bonus clip is find the right
vehicle
most people they overestimate their
importance in terms of success so I
think they say four they say this take
raising horses for example the jockey is
important but the horse is probably more
important so I think very often when
something is success
entrepreneurs like oh because I'm so
good right I mean I conquered a problem
I made it happen and all this stuff now
as I'm more mature I think finding the
right opportunity is probably way it's
like ten times more important so the
vehicle the vehicle and at the time I
picked the right vehicle because I was
remember the 13 businesses mister wrong
vehicle I was the wrong person but this
time that's why I don't believe the
whole thing all you got to be at the
right place at the right time you have
to be the right person in the right
place at the right time I was the right
person I had the skill I was online I
had to I have the suppliers right I was
making money to all this stuff now my
skills I have a platform to exercise my
talents and skills and money was coming
in the how come it took me so much
effort before to make $1000 right and
now like I just make that play yeah you
couldn't even stop the money I was like
I couldn't stop what changed yeah has I
picked the right vehicle do you remember
that first time where you made an amount
of money that even blew your mind like
oh [ __ ] this is possible ID number a
cheque that sticks out no it's not check
is all this money coming in mm-hmm and I
wasn't thinking about it I was getting
there just spending money and I was 27
yeah 27 years old I look at my bank
account hmm got a million dollars in
cash mm-hmm yeah not net worth cash
liquid liquid that's a lot of money
right
that's what I thought this is all money
right and this is this is from
copywriting in sales and affiliates or
how the phone or internet and the family
had multiple internet businesses this is
one thing to another I've got a bonus
clip from Dan on how to find true
fulfillment that I think you're gonna
really enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
time to move from watching another video
to taking action in your life or your
business so here we go
question number one what is your why
number two what uncomfortable thing do
you need to get comfortable with and
number three what do you need to show up
to this week
you
years old one day I wake up keys are
coming down my cheek piano why is
talking to my wife my wife's like what's
going on right I said I don't know I've
never been and they had this feeling
it's like that this internal it's like a
depression right came from nowhere I've
never had this feeling before I've never
been depressed so this feeling and this
depression that just hit me I don't know
what's going on that's when I went on a
little bit journey more like a spiritual
journey when I wanted to find out okay
maybe what I've done in the first 10
years something was missing this formula
doesn't quite work kind of like what
Tony Robin talks about success without
fulfillment yeah I was at that point I
was trying to win the contest for the
track for fulfillment running on a
tractor but it does not work yeah
from then on everything I do and I study
a lot of different work I go back to my
business on a change everything hmm I'll
give you a perfect example before 30
years old every single business I have
I'm 100 percent shareholder mm-hmm I
have no partners no I could be given out
yeah after 30 years old every single
business I have everything that's
punishing that changed the way operator
raise your standard Apple epic or its
core value is that that people passion
[Music]
not one drop of most self-worth depends
on your acceptance of me
if you like this video check out the top
10 we did on dan locks mentor Dan Pena
the link is right next to me I think
you're gonna enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
self-esteem is the key to high
performance it's not work if you love
what you're doing but does that look
like your group